Welcome everyone.
This is the session
AMC 309.
Migrating your VMware workloads with on-premises
dependencies.
And if you came here today to learn
how AWS.
Design a set of services to help
you to migrate and modernize
from VMware.
Through the clouds at your own pace,
you're in the right place.
Today I'm sharing the stage with
my good friend Scott Rose.
And our guest.
Travis
McVeigh
from Caesars Entertainment.
All right, this is our agenda for today.
And without any further ado,
let's get into the good stuff.
Good I've
been in this situation before.
And if you are a professional,
Working on
Traditional infrastructure on premise,
you can probably relate to those challenges.
And if you do, I can feel your
pain. I've been there for several
years
and plenty of time, and
I can tell you.
I know it's very, very hard and
it's very, very difficult.
Whenever we are talking about
administering and running on premises
infrastructure.
I would like to
Ask you guys a question.
Is there still
Worry
To run
on premises infrastructure.
That is still a good thing. There is still a
valid approach.
Well, As it
turns out,
It's very, very difficult.
To actually get a good grasp
of the TCO
of running on-premises infrastructure.
Particularly on some aspects
like personnel.
The cost of running infrastructure.
The cost of the facilities.
And the technical debt
that we accumulate over time.
It's very difficult to get a good estimate.
And if you don't know how it actually costs,
it's very difficult to make informed
decisions about if it's still worthy
to run on on-prem infrastructure.
Or
should I take a different path?
Over time,
We have this compound effect.
Of the business drivers
and the technical drivers
to actually push.
The idea of migrating
our infrastructure.
Through the cloud
And with that
compound force
we can actually
Make an informal decision on
should I go or not.
Is it worthwhile?
Should I go all in?
What is the best strategy and etc.
for me
to actually go
and. Start this journey.
Whenever you think of this,
of course,
there are some challenges that
you encounter,
and of course that will come to your mind.
The first one is that
How long does it take to migrate?
Is that easy?
Should I do it at a fast pace or
should I take it slow?
And if I take it slow,
how can I demonstrate
that I am generating value out of it?
How can I demonstrate, oh, we are already
uh. Taken
to the hanging low hanging fruit
and to our leadership,
oh, is it good? We are making good progress,
and this is good.
The next challenge is
As of lately
we are having an
ever growing pressure.
About sovereignty.
We still have to
keep our data.
On premises
We have regulatory requirements.
We have government mandates.
And they say I want to control the
facility
where my data
lives.
This is one more argument because
There's a
huge chance that
you don't have a region nearby
and you cannot say oh the region is in my country
or eventually have a local zone in
your country.
So you need
A strategy
whenever you are being audit
for one of these government bodies
say OK
how are you handling
my data sovereignty requirements.
Not to mention, and I bet that you
heard a lot.
This
Last days about Gen AI.
All of a lot of customers
that I deal with
are always asking us.
How can I run
A G AI
augmented application.
On-prem
How can I run inference on prem?
From my data sets.
And still meet
my
data
sovereignty requirements.
These challenges
are imposing
a great pressure
on
the movement to migrate
from on premises
to the cloud.
And now
you're probably
thinking
how AWS can help me
on that intent.
AWS
has designed a strategy.
To help our customers
to migrate.
At their own pace
from on prem.
To the ideally
to the cloud region.
But if not possible at first,
we can give you
steps along the way.
We can give you a journey
so you can.
Migrate
You can.
Meet your requirements.
You can tackle those challenges that
we just saw.
And you are, you can
Quickly demonstrate
that you are
living that traditional world,
and then you are stepping into
the clouds.
This strategy is what we call
AWS
where you need it.
And it's a set of services that allow you
To migrate
from your own premise.
To either
AWS outpost,
which is very, very close to you.
AWS outputs can be placed on your
data center.
It can be placed on a call facility
of your choice.
And that's
the closest that we can get.
With AWS services.
Or
you can take the step of migrating to a
local zone.
A local zone is our infrastructure place
it on.
Metropolitan areas, selected metropolitan
areas.
And it's also
A valid path for you
to address
sovereignty requirements.
Because AWS
can sure can guarantee to you that our
infrastructure, it's running
at that metropolitan area.
And this might be enough
for a lot of governments and entities
that require data residency.
With that
We can create a journey.
So you should always be aiming
to get to the region whenever possible,
but if not,
We can give you
Steps along the way
where you are effectively running.
On AWS
On a cloud infrastructure.
Cloud assets that are futureproof
and that can pave the way
for you. To finally
migrate as much as possible
from your own premises.
Through the cloud.
There are several ways for you,
several paths.
That you can take
To actually
Endured this journey
Of course, the most common one
is the lift and shift approach.
In which our customers
want to just
show very quick results.
And they just take the workloads as they
are. And they migrate
either to outposts or local zones.
And this is totally fine. This is
absolutely fine.
What you could do
is along the way.
Try to modernize and try
to shift gears a little bit,
experiencing some some of our
managed services
like managed databases,
like managed containers.
So you don't need to install your database
on top of VC 2 anymore.
You don't need to manage your Kubernetes
or your Docker.
And you can leverage our offerings
that will certainly
Alleviate
What we call the undifferentiated
heavy lifting.
Which is those activities that
are fundamental
but does not bring
too much added value.
Whenever you are choosing
which route to take.
It's important to factor in.
The timelines of your migration.
What kind of requirements do you have?
If you are running out of contract with
facilities,
if you have outdated hardware,
if you are expiring contracts
and warranties.
And this is really, really important for you.
To decide
which one to take.
But the best course of action is
to take action now.
Don't wait.
That's what we are here for,
to help you
to finally
make that decision,
and we are here to help you.
To make that happen.
I'll hand it over to you, Scott, my good
friend. Scott.
All right, thanks so much, Frankie.
Hi folks, my name is Scott Rose, colleague
with Frankie, been with AWS for a little
over 5 years, and really, really excited
to be speaking about how we've helped many
customers such as yourselves
assess, optimize, and migrate their
workloads over to AWS and specifically
how to do that into our hybrid edge port.
on-prem portfolio outpost
in local zones we've been doing it for the
better part of 5 years, almost since Outpost
was originally launched,
and we're really excited to have Travis here from
Caesars to talk about his journey.
Caesars was one of the original customers
that deployed Outpost. You'll have some great context
coming from him as well.
Now here at AWS and you guys have all been in a bunch of
sessions. We threw a lot of tech at you
and we're going to do that here in a moment as well, but
we also want to talk about the commercials because
when we deal with migration
situations we're typically dealing with environments
that are 1020,
sometimes 30 years old.
We're starting to see some
interesting licensing cost changes. Obviously VMware
is one of them,
but also the cost in
operating and maintaining extremely old.
Legacy environments such as mainframe environments
and it has become extremely difficult for these
organizations
to continue to fund and continue to budget
operations that were designed essentially decades
ago, not to mention most of the expertise
or those workloads themselves are just nowhere
clear optimized for current
product and application requirements. So we're
seeing the cost elements become
a very important consideration, of course,
in addition to the technical one.
So with that said,
AWS over the last 6 to 9 months
has really spent a lot of time helping
out the funding situation,
the migration
compensation situation I'll call it, in
that we want to make sure when you're analyzing
this, don't worry about
any kind of duplicate licensing costs, double
bubble type
situations. We will have a migration
program and a suitable. Funding
program to help alleviate most if
not all of those costs and both Frankie and
myself have been involved in some fairly large customers.
When we calculated up the size of
those funding programs, they are quite
significant. So don't be afraid to bring those
commercial concerns to us well
in advance of the technical and
the architectural
analysis that obviously is going to be happening in parallel
for your migration assessment.
So there's a lot of ways to approach this from
a financial standpoint. We can do this
in the form of credits towards our
ProServe organization, working to
scope those projects again
in a sequence and in a dollar
amount that makes sense.
We have a lot of partners that are involved in this as well.
Most of our customers are
engaged with multiple system integrators
that have been contracted to do
application management and operations.
For many years,
so our funding programs are designed to also
work directly from
a commercial standpoint
into those partners themselves. And
then again, looking at this from a going
forward standpoint, obviously AWS
is cloud computing. It's based on a consumption
model. A lot of your on-prem infra
might still be
purchased and budgeted from a CE
standpoint, so we try to bridge those
two. The net net is that if you're
doing a migration program. With AWS,
we're looking forward from a standpoint of
how that estate is going to look on running
on cloud native infra, in this case cloud
native infra on-prem, such as with outposts
and local zones, and to negate out
any kind of duplicate costs that
you might be calculating so you can be assured
you can move forward and it's a single layer
cost, not multiple layers, because you're going
from one platform,
say VMware or an older
set of infrastructure over to AWS.
OK, so as we move forward, Frankie had
a, you know, a bit of a complicated, uh, or just,
you know, fairly uh text heavy
slide on, on the various migration steps, and
it really just consolidates down to this.
Um, it's a fairly simple
staging or sequencing as far as how
we want to look at your state, what
we want to do from a standpoint of
moving legacy applications or legacy
VMs over onto the proper
AWS footprint.
Obviously the bottom of the layer is the very
fast but also very useful EC2
lift and shift and then simply moving up the
scale.
Some customers want to modernize those
virtual applications, those virtual machines into
containers.
Maybe we want to move a step forward, add
managed database services such as RDS,
or take the final leap where we're completely
refactoring some of those applications and
going, say with
a fully serverless deployment.
Of course we can do all this, we've been doing all this for
quite some time.
My experience
with migration customers and we've been doing
many over the past 3 to 4 years and that
that that uh speed has been picking up. It's
not a one-stop shop.
Many of these environments we're doing,
say, a canvas of the environment first
with the lift and shift, and then there's a fraction
that gets containerized
and a further fraction where we're deploying
database managed services. So it's not just
a one blob, it's several different layers
of this cake.
And then just to strike
the on-prem.
Versus the regional element with outposts
with local zones,
we can typically take it all the way up into the managed
database services and then region
is of course where you'll find our scalable
serverless platform such as
Lambi. So again, just a little bit of context
and cut through from the standpoint of the
slide that Frankie showed a bit earlier.
Now earlier last year
we launched our 2nd generation outpost,
and we're talking about this because a lot of our
VMware migration opportunities are
coming at us
with hard requirements to stay on-prem. They
want to deploy with cloud native infra, obviously
leveraging AWS,
but not into the region, has to stay on-prem
for a variety of reasons data residency,
latency,
proximity to other on-prem assets,
say, other storage or other compute assets.
And so our infra basically has to sit
adjacent to those existing
solutions. So that's what Outpost was specifically
built for.
The second gen Outpost came out mid
early last year,
this year 2025, and we've been scaling it
up over the last 6 to 9
months. And this has been working out
amazingly for our migration
opportunities, our customers with migration
use cases.
Why? Because many of those environments
that we are analyzing, we're going in and we're
seeing
tens and tens of thousands
of these CPUs, hundreds
of terabytes, sometimes into the petabyte
type storage range,
so the kind of scale that's needed
to migrate those workloads over
to an AWS outpost
footprint can be quite significant.
So with the new
High compute density EC2
instances that were launched with OutpostG 2
are parallel networking substructure
which doesn't just help
say high IO data center applications and databases,
but also some of our customers want to multiplex
other workloads on them,
network intensive workloads.
OutpostGen 2 serves as a very,
very solid. Footprint for both the standard
IT applications coming over
from VMware as well as perhaps some
high performance databases and other
suitable applications and categories
of applications, and those all can be multiplexed
on the same rack infrastructure. And
so what we're talking about here is we're talking
about customers who are ripping up
extremely large fleets of legacy
infra. A lot of it running VMware, a lot of it
running throughout multiple sites and
consolidating a lot of that down onto
outpost rack footprints, sometimes
in the dozens and sometimes in the hundreds
of rack size,
but that footprint turns out to be
a lot smaller and a lot more efficient
than what that legacy infrastructure footprint
looked like prior to getting on with the
project itself. So as I mentioned, the
new instances that came with outpost
2,
from a stand, most importantly from a standpoint of
the CPU and the memory density
gave us very, very good metrics
to go and calculate and create much
more dense configurations than was
currently deployed
with the previous Edge Infra.
We also have a set of other
instances in this outpost such as bare metal which
was designed for some of our
very high performance application customers
such as in our Finserve
segment as well as in our telco segment
and then coming soon we'll have a next
generation GPU instance, not
just for graphics instances of course. This will
be a GPU instance specifically designed
for. Or
at the edge inference and perhaps even training
as well depending on how you're setting up
your models. So this rack
has been built forward proof from a standpoint
of the type of workloads that our customers
need for the next several years, and
some of these are just in the design phases. So we want
to make sure we're skating to where the
puck needs to be from an aspect of your
on-prem requirements. And the migration
situation as we're specifically talking about in this
session has really, really
pushed the limits of the next generation
densities that are on these outposts,
and what's not even being shown here is in
about a couple of months we'll have yet another wave
of brand new, brand new, even higher
performing instances that AWS
will be launching. So
stick around for details on that.
Coming back to the migration and coming back to
the VMware story in a second, what we've seen
with customers who are actively doing this today,
we've all been in these enterprise
IT environments for quite some time throughout our careers,
and you think we got it. You think that
this should take maybe a couple of weeks to assess.
It's not. This is taking months.
Some of our customers are taking years because
What we're discovering is a lot of these environments
have basically sat there and they haven't
been optimized. They haven't really been
updated other than, say, operating system
and firmware, so the architecture
doesn't make sense. Like a specific example,
we'll go into
the VM disk manifest and we'll
see VMs where there might be one CPU
and 700 gigabytes, 760.
Gigabytes of memory, a very asymmetrical VM,
and we try to find out what was that used for and
do we need to find a suitable EC2 instance to house that
and no one in the organization seems to know where that comes
from. So when you do that at scale
and you go through this with hundreds and thousands
and tens of thousands of VMs, really
the time
to do all that really, really creeps up.
So how are we solving that? How are we
correcting that? How are we creating a better
assess and optimize plan?
Well, of course we have been analyzing this,
and our solution, of course, is going to be a set
of agentic-based optimizations
and assessment tools to be able to go
in, analyze the environment, and
not just find out kind of on a chunky
basis how many CPUs,
how much memory, how much storage
the existing environment is. You guys probably already
know that to actually go in and determine,
hey, based on the Usage of these VMs
we think that this class of VMs deserves
sort of a higher priority or an
advanced schedule of assessment
versus some other VMs that haven't been
used and have been idle for months. So
that's one
fairly easy
optimization path that we can take
with our AI-based tools.
The other key one is how do we
analyze
the networking elements. So we see a lot of customers
that have
not just the compute and storage but
a fairly custom.
Networking shell that exists
around those VMware environments. What do we do with that?
How do we take what might be, say, a very
flat layer 2 environment
and convert that over to, say, a more scalable,
routable layer 3?
Our AI tools will help analyze and assess
the networking
aspects, not just from the aggregation
layer, but all the way down into the
VVC layer which will interact
with the EC2 instances.
And I think most importantly again, if
you have an environment where it's maybe
a couple dozen or a couple 100 VMs we probably
can, we can do that all fairly manually,
old school
spreadsheets, but if we're dealing with
tens and tens of thousands of VMs
across multiple sites, that's not all gonna
happen at once. So what becomes.
Really handy
is how do we do proper wave analysis?
How do we analyze it and then determine how
to reload into your
environment in waves that make sense
from a standpoint of the criticality of
those applications being migrated from a VM
over to EC2 or perhaps being containerized
at the same time.
So all this is basically being done by AWS
Transform.
This is a new tool that we launched earlier
this year and specifically
designed to basically analyze
the variety of
migration workloads VMware,
mainframe,
also virtualized but non-VM based
legacy virtualized applications
and determine not just the infrastructure.
Path but perhaps to also
suggest and optimize the coding of
the application itself. So as an
example,
taking mainframe legacy cobalt
applications and translating those over into
modern Java applications. So AWS
Transform is both an infrastructure
analyzer and modeler, but also
a discrete
application optimization tool,
OK. And there are several modules
or several
capabilities that transform
will take care of and whether again we're
specifically talking VMware or most
of our customers when they come to us, it's
first a VMware problem. But then it
changes into a multi-application problem
including legacy, non-virtualized databases,
mainframe
applications, very old Java
applications, etc.
So there's multiple
interfaces that transform is going to
help in, and we can go into our
own breakout session specifically on this. I want to make
sure we get to
Travis's section, but just as an example, just
this one
segment around
network conversion and migration.
This is some details as far as how
Transform would take care of
from an aspect of analyzing the source
of virtual NSX switches,
of course analyzing the RV2
files, as well as any third
party firewall or load
balancers or
application centric infrastructure such
as Cisco.
Determines the appropriate new
topology going forward and then
creates the translated AWS,
in this case the AWS network entities. Again
this is just the networking aspect.
There's a similar compute and storage aspect.
There's a wave analysis that goes into this, so it's
a fairly comprehensive
AI
tool that helps take that multi-month
migration problem statement
and helps us accelerate that by at least 2,
if not 3 orders of magnitude.
So obviously the key benefits that
we can realize from this one
from the aspect of cost and time,
we analyze the environment not just from a standpoint
of consolidation but
optimization moving forward with
the additional variable of doing this on prem.
We know we can do this in the region. A lot of you probably
do leverage
resources in the region, but we are talking about
doing all of this
onto on-prem cloud native
infra such as outposts, such as local zones
that have slightly different nuances because that
physical infrastructure is sitting
inside your environment.
So we analyze your use costs from the standpoint
of your existing infra,
your existing licensing, and try to figure
out how we net all that out so
that it's a single layer.
Cost structure from where you are right now
to where you'll be with AWS. No parallel,
no redundant, no double bubble costs.
We want to speed up the migrations as much
as possible. AI is great, but
by no means is it perfect.
All right, it's going to help us squeeze down a
lot of the analysis time, but there's still
going to be obviously a lot of
manual intervention, but it's going to be orders
of magnitude quicker than probably doing this
from scratch or doing this in fairly
old school. Ways as we do
this we're going to bring AWS security
principles to the picture as well. You hear time
and time again
that security is our top priority.
So when we look at how we're interfacing into
our infrastructure and into your infrastructure,
we'll be bringing in those security
primitives and principles in addition
to the obvious the migration activity
itself. So security, it kind of comes
along for free,
but it's a very important industrialized.
Component in all of our modern well
practiced well architected
migration
projects and then innovate at scale
we of course work at scale. I mean of course we
can do this in small environments but
we've already engineered this to work across
hundreds, thousands, hundreds of
thousands of VMs and that
typically is the operating size we're seeing
for most mid to large size customers coming
to us
across multiple sites, sometimes continent.
in scale, this is something AWS
has become
obviously extremely good at and we've learned the patterns
to go from those those small POCs
up into those large production environments.
OK, so I hope this kind of give you a little bit
of whetting the appetite as far as how
we do it, how we approach it, and what we use it for.
And now I'm very happy to turn the
presentation over to Travis and hear about his
journey with Caesar's on Outpost.
Thank you, Travis very much.
Uh, thank you all for, uh, for having me. My name
is, uh, Travis McVeigh. Uh, I've been with
Caesars, um, Entertainment for
4 years in, uh, August.
I'm actually part of, uh, the digital part of the
business that runs the sports book and
race book and i gaming sector,
um, not so much the, the hotel
and, uh, you know, the, the palace that you will see
here, but if you go into the sports book,
all those kiosks, if you wanna go place a bet,
that is all managed by, uh, by my, by my
team. Um, so
first let's go into just a little bit of background of
what Caesars Entertainment is. Uh,
you know, we all know what Caesars Palace is, but
we, we're, we're a bit more than, than just, just
the palace, right?
So we're the largest casino entertainment
company in the United States and
one of the world's most diver diversified casino
entertainment, uh, providers.
Uh, we began in Reno, actually,
Nevada in 1937.
And uh we've grown through uh
development of new resorts, expansions
and acquisitions.
Um, you may or may not know that, but uh
we actually operate several
brands here in in Vegas and other places
such as the Horseshoe,
uh, the Link, the Flamingo, um,
and other big iconic brands like uh El
Dorado,
and then of course Caesars and Jara's.
Um,
we offer a full suite of mobile and
online gaming and sport betting, uh, experiences,
and it's, uh, all tied, uh, to
our industry leading Caesars reward, uh,
loyalty program.
Uh, we focus on building
value with, uh, with our guests in a unique
combination of these services,
and, uh, we're committed to our employees, suppliers
and communities and the environment through our
people, Planet, uh, play framework.
So just a couple of stats, uh, it.
Yes, we do have over 50,000
employees.
Um Again, I was kind of
explaining some of the different iconic brands
that that we do manage and and and do
and what Caesar's is is doing, especially
here in local Vegas.
Um, but let's dig into, to
my part of the business, uh, which is, you know,
online gambling. Um,
you know, 2018, FASFA was, uh,
repealed, and, uh, it's been kind of like a rocket
ship, gold mine, uh, whatever you wanna,
wanna call it.
Um, it didn't, it didn't exist. Uh, now it's a
20 billion plus annual
industry. We've grown 10 times
since 2018 and almost
60%, more than half the
US is allowed to gamble now,
including Missouri, which just went live
on Monday.
But that's not why you're here. We're, we're
here about, uh, migration,
you know, VMware to, to outposts, why
we did it, what, what's here, right? Uh, so let's
get into some of the, the bad before we get into
some of the, the good of, of what we
were running.
So we had complexity, um,
you know, I don't know about all of you, but our dev and
production didn't exactly
match,
um, you know, it's very easy to just scale
and build apps on AWS,
um, but we have a very, very
interesting problem that we have to solve that not a lot
of. Industries have to solve,
uh, and that is uh the wire Act.
So in order for us to take a bet in the
US, the bet actually has to
take place in the state
you're like, well how do you do that? Well, uh, uh, it's
up to, you know,
the legal,
uh, rules of what that is,
but effectively the transaction has to occur
on prem.
so I can never move
my betting engine
off of
on-prem. It has to stay in the state.
And what's er really funny is sometimes
it's in the back of a casino, cos that's the only place that
I'm actually allowed to do it.
Um, and because of that, you know, I have
a VMware workload that's in there, and I'm
have my devs testing in, in AWS,
and then you get some weird things like your, the,
the, the container won't just even run
because one of the, you know, we're running EVC
on some of these things and, and the, the,
the proc options that
the, the CPU options that the app actually needs
to run. Isn't available
and uh you have to fix that, right?
It's working everywhere else and in this one state it it
the deployment fails.
So lots of, lots of complexity
uh around the data residency and
then not matching.
We also have the cost, right? Uh, so, so,
you know, here we have maybe
HP software, here we have Dell, here
you have this vendor XYZ.
Uh, and VMware is giving you that, that
abstraction layer, but you still have to, you still
have to upgrade the firmware on these. You still have to make
sure that things are all working
and not to mention if you have some software that's
managing the, the VMware build
in its own, in itself kind of in its
own bubble, um, how to manage the pat.
Matching of all of those environments, you know, we're, we have
over 30 jurisdictions where we have these
environments at and, and to upgrade
all of those VMV centers,
um, another part is, is how do
you get your, your golden image out to
all these environments,
um, you know,
it, it, it's not, it's not easy.
User experience, um, you know,
if you go and you place a bet in Caesars Palace
or Link.
Do you know whether it's running on Outpost or VMware?
You don't care,
you just wanna make sure your bet goes.
That's a big thing that that we had to understand is
we have all this complexity, we're trying to manage
all of this. By the end of the day, what actual
customer value are we adding
for all this headache?
But, but it's a good question, and, and
we had to ask ourselves that. Do we wanna go build it
ourselves and do bare metal?
Do we wanna continue with VMware, or do we
wanna run, uh, an outpost and, and
just kind of ob obfuscate all
that away so that we can focus on higher
customer value,
uh, items.
And the last piece is, is performance.
You know, yes,
you can make your VMware environment
performant, but I mean,
just show of hands, how many people have seen someone
that says, hey, I'm gonna make my database faster
by putting 60 CPUs on it.
Um, yeah, that's, that's, that's not gonna
work. Um, and, and
what really happens with Outposts is it
forces you to rethink your deployment
strategy and, and we'll get into that in, uh,
in a little bit more.
So what did our
VMware architecture effectively look like and
why is it gonna be easy for us to to
migrate things because uh I'm gonna explain how
fast we do these and you're gonna be like
you're you're lying, so let's let's get
that out of the way. I, I'm not lying, all the things I'm
gonna tell you are true.
What we were running was Capi, which is uh
the open source version of Kubernetes
on VMware.
Almost all of our workloads are.
Uh,
containerized running in Kubernetes,
and the only things outside of that were our
database VMs, uh, just because
we can't get, uh, the the recovery
time, uh, and the recovery point objective
that we need in Cube.
Uh, we're close. I want to get those things in there so
bad, but we're just not quite there,
um, and then we have the storage gateway so
that, uh, we can manage,
uh, backups and get them off site to meet our, uh,
regulatory
requirements.
So for us it was a pretty simple stack, but
we. Continue to drive
this way to make sure that the dev
experience is the same
even with the the hardware being different, right?
We wanted the devs to be able to create a container,
to create an app,
and deploy it whether it was in AWS or
within VMware and you know all the Kubernetti
stories are true, right?
As long as my team managed that
infrastructure, it was the same.
But again, I, I, when I'm talking about what the
difference is, is my team had to deal with
all of that difference. We had to manage
Cappy. We had to manage our upgrades. We had
to make sure that the golden image was there
and would boot.
We had to manage all the firewall rules to make sure all
the communication would work.
And you know,
we love hammering our VCenter for all of our
um, our CSI volumes that Kubernetes
is constantly doing. So I don't know if you've
tried that, but it's, uh, it's, it, it can
take a while to move a.
Move a cloud uh native
disc is what they call it,
from one VM to another when you're when you're doing your
upgrades. So
what lives on our outpost racks now?
So
what we've done is
we've moved to where we have C
nodes and M nodes um
for, for the different applications.
So here we have our C nodes for our database.
So if you look at the previous slide,
right, we've just moved the VMDBs
over into C node
VMs. We then
have our EKS on outpost, so that
now I'm not upgrading Cappy, I'm not
testing Cappy, I'm not trying to make sure all those
things are working,
and I don't have this single VMware instance
that's in my dev
that I have one engineer that can iterate on slowly.
Now we have AWS with EKS and I can,
I can rapidly make sure that all of our
Damon sets and helm charts and things
are working. We do have a
couple of extra
resources that we do cause you know, now, now
we're wanting to use Route 53, more cloud
native services, but you have to think of things
uh in a little bit of a different way. Outpost
is anchored to a region.
Well, what happens if that connection to
the region goes down,
right? It's a, it's a very serious thing that you
have to think about. It's a different way to think
about because you are dependent on the region,
even though the, the instances are there,
you're still dependent on it. So we wanted to put
in as much resilience as we
could that, you know, we can serve stale
cash when, when things are because
our IPs aren't really changing. You can see
we're, we have a pretty static item, we just need to make sure
ingress gets into the cluster and then
everything works.
So that's why we have this our Route 53.
Um, managed
EC2 instances still have the storage
gateway, so you can see our, ours was,
you know, you could say lift and shift, but the thing that made it
lift and shift for us was
effectively Kubernetes, right? We,
the, the stories of, you know, we wanna be able
to move clouds easily with our apps, uh,
we were able to actually test that theory and,
and go forward with it, um, you
know, in this case it's private cloud to, to
outpost, but.
Uh, really worked.
You're like, wait, I didn't see any S3, I love
S3.
You're right, um, S3 is going to add a
ton of.
Nodes to your outpost rack, it's also gonna
add to the cost,
so you gotta really think, is that what I wanna do? And
like I said, we have 34 +
jurisdictions that we're doing in, so every single
time I'm adding
cost, I gotta multiply that by
30, and you can see the number gets up there very,
very quickly. So it's how can we be.
Adaptive to what we need but also
cost conscious for the CFO.
So what we've also done is, is
tried to, you know, the dependency of
a single outpost is that it's
tied to availability zone, right? So you have to think
of an outpost rack
as an availability zone. It is not a region,
it is a zone.
I don't have an extra SLA. I don't have an extra
failover. Yes, if a, if a.
Uh, if a
server fails,
I have redundancy built into that.
If a network switch fails, I have redundancy
into that, but if the whole rack goes down
or my service link goes down, I'm tied
to that availability zone, and some of you will
probably have the question,
were you impacted by the US East One region?
Yes, we were,
we were very, very
fortunate in mitigating it because of our
design of utilizing a shared BPC
for most of our services to route
over the logical gateway. If you looked at Frank's
earlier slides, he had some.
He had one little bullet that said, you know,
networking via the logical gateway,
and we've really pushed that to try and make our service
end points over that
so that if our service link goes down that single
point of failure,
um, we can still route back out and
take a bet, right, because that's our transaction, we
wanna be able to take a bet.
Um, we then put some managed nodes in the other availabilities
nodes, uh, uh, availability zones
again to make sure that, that, you know, any kind
of services that are running in those, um,
so if that availability goes down,
we can still make sure that traffic is, is flowing
and updating such as, uh,
you know, Route 53, etc.
And then what we do is we split our
outpost.
Um, it does open
the option that if any availability zone
fails, we would be impacted.
But if an availability zone is impacted,
not all of our sites are. So it's again a
design decision. It could be different for your business
model. This is what we decided, uh,
you know, work with your account managers and your essays
to really try to figure out what works for
you, um, because, you know, this,
it's not one size fits all. You have to figure out what works
for your business,
what your resiliency is, and what you're, you're, you
know, willing to, to, to have.
Slotting, does anybody know what slotting is?
Yeah, I have, it's one hand, OK, so.
VMware has made this
so simple, right? Like if you think about
before VMware, what did you have to do? You would go and you'd
figure out how many servers I could fit
in a rack,
how much power I have, um, thank
you for all your power guidance back in my early
career, Brad,
and uh, you know,
you, you could only fit so much in a rack, and
then by that you can only fit so many apps in
that rack.
You, you, you do go back to that a little
bit with outpost, and you have to really rethink it
because what I could do is I could overcommit my VMware
resources, right? So if you want a VM you want a VM,
yeah, sure,
as long as I hit my 6 to 1 ratio and as long
as my critical apps are, are right size
enough, um, I'm OK.
Well, that, that's great, but now I have
all of these VMs sitting that have all of these
massive resource requirements that probably
aren't real.
The other thing that you have to think about too is that,
you know, for us we had Kubernetes, so think about
the number of schedulers we have. We have
the, the base
host which has, you know, CPU
you have the VMware scheduler,
we then have the virtual machine which is also
scheduling CPUs.
I then have Kubernetes and then I have my
container. Wow.
Since I don't have the VMware orchestration
layer now and I'm running right on the,
the droplet of the server of uh the
outpost,
I'm getting a 1 to 1 CPU so I'm no longer
having that CPU swap, the CPU wait
time, that's, that's gone.
The CPU wait, the CPU ready that you've been
sitting and looking at your graphs forever
and you're like, why is my VM slow? That, that's
not, that doesn't exist,
but you have to put.
The work up front,
spend
time
right sizing your stuff, otherwise you're gonna buy
way too much hardware.
And
you're gonna be looking at what do I do with this extra
hardware, um,
so we're seeing 4 times
performance because we're no longer swapping
with our database nodes, right? Our database nodes
were again the bet has to take place on prem.
Well, what does that mean? That means that I have to have a transaction.
Transaction hits a database.
If that's swapping in and out while it's trying to replicate
and be highly available,
and then now I don't need any of that swapping.
And then what what do we do is we took,
we realized that we didn't need our nodes to be as big.
So now in order to strip it across, I
get these extra slots that now I have
extra uh compute Kubernetes nodes that are
very optimized for CPU and now I can
put different database technologies
that before I was super scared to put onto
in Cube, and I'm ready to go. So the last
thing, like I said, is we need to get our
other database nodes off of these dedicated.
Instant slots, I can move those into Kubernetes
and I'm gonna actually be able to flow my
environment,
much like a DRS or an HA item,
but using Kubernetes to manage that for me and
not all the underlying VMware
stuff I'm, I'm paying for, right.
So What
was our journey like?
Um, we, we,
my team moves and they move fast,
so we, we've tried to figure out everything that we could. We
designed it, we took the time up front to slot it, right
size it.
We worked with the account team to get a
test environment up to so we could make sure
that it worked,
and then we put the pedal to the metal. So
in July we had 4 racks installed
and we migrated 2 states.
In August we got 1 more rack installed,
and I we migrated 2 states.
In September.
We installed 5 more racks
and we migrated a state every
single week.
We got our downtime.
That I couldn't serve customers down to 2
hours.
We then figured out new ways to do our database
migrations over the logical gateways so that we
could replicate things so that when our cutover happened,
it was almost instantaneously
and then
through. Um, if,
if you're, uh, familiar with anti-infinity rules,
you, you have to think about how some of the services
work, right? So for us,
we don't like a single point of failure, and,
um, we had to identify, you know, what
services we wanted to use, and so one
of the key pieces is
you do lose the hyperplane on outpost,
right? So I can't use a network load
balancer in the rack, right?
I can use one in the region and forward it,
or I'm given an ALB option.
Depending on your slotting, ALB
may work very well for you.
For us it didn't, right? We, we had to have so much
capacity for the upgrades and the managed service
of the ALB because it's designed
to run in region,
not an outpost.
So again, it's depending on your solution, but
we, we. Decided that that wouldn't
work for us because we have a single rack, we
need to do it. So again,
we're constantly what the, the point I'm trying
to make is, is that
while we're migrating, we're learning and
we're improving, and it's an important thing that
you do as you do waves, right? We're doing states
because it's the same app over and over again.
But you know when you stop and look at most
applications, whether it's a web tier, it's an app tier, it's a database,
and it has dependencies,
right? Once you get good and once you figure out what the dependencies
are, you're just rinse and repeating, right?
You get on that rotation and, and that, and that's what's
important to, to really
recognize. Hey, I'll, I'll keep going through the timeline.
October we installed, uh, another 6 racks.
November, uh, unfortunately,
uh, December I was hoping that we would have 20,
um,
we, uh.
We're, we're hoping to restart that, uh,
backup, um, but we did improve our uh
DR design which we're really excited about,
uh, because
effectively we're able to use
our regional availability
zone designs
and just replicate it now to outpost, which
again is, you know, if you're thinking
that way, cloud native and you're thinking about multi
availability or multi-regional,
that, that is just gonna help you with your,
your overall outpost design.
So we go back to the challenges
that we talked about and it's like, OK, so
what was, what was it? We had experience and
complexity. I now have a single
AMI
and I can share it with all the outposts because it's in the same,
you know, it's in, it's in the account and I can, I can deploy
it fast.
I talked about the 1 to 1 CPU.
Sometimes it's, you know, depending on how we configure
the app, I've, we've gotten 3 times performance.
Uh, I, I know I said 4 earlier, uh,
we're trying to constantly tweak things and make things
better, but again, because I don't have to have
that 6 to 1 ratio, I have a
1:1 ratio to really think
about that.
Does my database actually need 24 CPUs?
If it was running on bare metal,
how many CPUs would you give it?
Probably not 24, I'd start with 12,
see how that works.
So really think about that and what it works
and then think about the slotting because you
know again,
every slot
is gonna consume that and again with
the new gen twos you get a lot more
scale, a lot more uh these are still the
the the gen ones, but uh it's it's
important to to think about.
And then for us it was guaranteed pricing,
so I, I don't know how many of you are interacting
with with Broadcom, but we were very nervous
when that conversation was starting.
Um, and, uh, it didn't seem
to matter the number of things we changed
in the equation. The number always ended up
being the same at the end. Um, I don't know
how that works, but, um,
we, we, we wanted to make sure that our,
our pricing was, was guaranteed, uh,
so that we could commit to the business that this
is what our cost is going to be year over year
and this is what it's going to be to add a new state
and um that was, that was really
important and I think the last piece that's
really important
is it's not just.
VMware, it's, it's not right. You have
your storage vendors, right? Like how many of you
go in, you love the storage,
you love all that, it gets bought by another company, all of
a sudden the price goes through the roof, or they
are decomming that now you're having to migrate
it, right? How much effort, how much time are your
team spending
to move.
Storage devices,
and what value did that bring to your customers?
0.
So you spent all that engineering time,
you spent all of that capital, you
spent all that operational cost, all the
planning to move it so that there was 0
downtime, you celebrated, it was so great,
and your customers saw
that much value.
Right, like that, and that's the key piece, right?
How, how do, how do I put that in terms that
you, you know, your, your C-suite understands
is, is that, that, that's the, that's the selling piece,
and that was what we, we really wanted to do.
And the last piece is, uh, is hardware, right? Uh, you know, I mentioned,
you know, you'll get into a hardware vendor.
You fully know how to support it. You'll buy their
management software to handle all the firmware
upgrades,
and then they get bought out or
they no longer support that. And now you're
going to their version too, and there's no upgrade
path and no,
it, it, it's constant cost
that again, you know,
Frank was, uh, and Scott were talking about the
hidden costs that you just
don't really think about unless you kind of take a step back
and you're like,
hold on,
what am I actually delivering to my customer?
Is my customer the dev? Is my customer actual
end user?
And uh that's that's what we really sat and
thought thought about before we went and
did all you know we could have done bare metal Kubernetes.
I have full, full faith in my team
we could have done it we could have done it very well
and on paper it would have looked cheaper
but then when I think about all the vendor and the
swaps and all that.
What value?
Um, so, you know, I've, I've kind of hit
on several of these, and I feel like I'm going a
little fast, um, but, uh, you know,
lessons learned.
Plan your deployment slotting. I, I
know I keep bringing this up, but slotting is so important.
It's a whole new paradigm shift,
and every single managed service that you want
will also consume a slot, right? So if you,
you, you know, it was a great slide that showed that you could
go to EC-2s and then you could go to
a managed RDS.
Well, managed RDS is still gonna consume a slot.
You don't get it for free.
That's going to be used.
And if you want it redundant, that's
now two slots that you've taken up.
You want an ALB that's going to take slots.
They also have to do upgrades. Well, in order to
do an upgrade, you no downtime. You
have to deploy that third one.
Decomm the other one,
right, so you have to have that room, that elastic
capacity that that's not necessarily
there, um, and then
the storage gateways, they, they all consume
slots, and when we first went in there we didn't
think about that, we just went and we're like, yeah, this is what
we need. Fortunately we got the performance
increase that gave us that additional capacity,
but if you're not that lucky it could really put you into
a bad position when you're trying to set up and you, you
never want your first one to go bad, right?
So please learn that lesson,
Work with slotting, work with the teams to really
test the things that you want and make sure that it'll
fit. Backup
power I think that's so
simple, right?
Um,
one thing that hit us is, like I said, we, we
put things in the back sometimes of a casino,
so we would
have our VMware rack there and if the power went
out, which sometimes does because the
casino doesn't necessarily have a,
a, you know, production data center grade
UPS that it just automatically flips on,
um,
we power it back on
VMware would come on we.
Right click yes,
you're not a read only file system,
everything is good, next, next, next,
and then we're back up, right? And it would take, it would take, you
know, 15 minutes.
This is an entire cloud
that has to boot. It has to connect to the region.
It has to provision. It has to make sure
that it does all of its security checks, has to
set up all the metadata services that we take for
granted, you know, the metadata service that,
you know, sends who it is and it's IP
and everything, all of that has to, has to
power up and come online
and, and that takes hours. It's
not, it's not minutes,
so. Make sure you
have either
separate redundant power or you
purchase the UPS and you put it there so
that it will keep the rack on. I, I
just
please learn that lesson that I've gone
through and had to explain that you
won't have to.
Uh, I think the biggest thing that we did
is my team identified some of the single point
of failures of, uh, the, you know,
the service link like I talked about.
So what we did is we worked with the account team and we were
like, hey,
this is whole new for us.
What things could fail, what we don't know.
Let's put our brains together and think of
everything that could fail. What about a server
failing? What about the service link failing? What about
Route 53 going down?
What what are all of these things that could do, and
let's build runbooks and let's make sure our app
could, can, can go. Um,
and we did, and we, we tested them all, we had runbooks,
it was all great.
One thing I will also tell you is if you're gonna test
service link failure, test it for longer than 2
hours. It's, uh, it's helpful,
um, and then, you know, I've talked about the VMware
HA DRS a lot, so I don't wanna spend too
much time on it, and, and it kind of goes back to the slotting,
but it, it's again,
what do you really need to run, you know, it's, it's
real simple. Like if you run it in region, just
pick the version that you want to run
on that and, and hammer. It right. And if
you can't, you know, if you have a lower environment, you should
be able to just shift it over there,
test it, see what you get on those M5
an M5 and region is the same thing that's running
an outpost, so you should get the same
CPU memory performance that you're expecting,
same with a C7 and M7. But
you know, really test it.
Take the time to do it.
Uh, I think,
uh, and that's, that's all I have, so, yeah,
thanks, Travis,
thank you. Thank you so much.
Some closing thoughts before we go.
Please come to visit us
at the
AWS village.
There you have a kiosk talking
about migration and modernization.
You can see a real outpost wreck.
And there is also a kiosk for the local
zones.
Please don't forget to complete.
The post-event session survey.
And we will be taking questions.
At the back of the session.
Thank you all for coming.
Thank you, thank you.